hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
sars covi2 diagnostic workflow with the
geno extract flex t
and the fluorocycler xt
i am jennifer woods of labruts and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by brooker daltonix to learn more
visit brooker.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
i'd like to now welcome our speaker
dr colleen monahan
product manager for diagnostic systems
hane life science at broker company
dr monahan you may now begin your
presentation
hello everyone thank you for taking time
to join this webinar and learn more
about the broker source covet 2
diagnostic workflow with the geno
extract flex t and the fluro cycler xt
my name is colleen monahan i am product
manager for the diagnostic
instrumentation at brooker in niren in
germany
i've been product manager for high tech
and med tech industries for around 10
years my background is biomedical
engineering i earned my degree from the
university of ulster in jordanstown
which is close to my hometown of belfast
and my phd from the university of twente
in the netherlands
i have been with brooker for a short
time having joined in march and i must
say i am blown away with the high
quality of the solutions and i'm very
excited to share these with you today
this is a short overview of what i would
like to present today
the broker campus in niren in germany
was formerly hang life science i imagine
that many of you may be familiar with
bricker and i want to introduce you to
the hang life science part since this is
key to understanding our strengths in
terms of assay development
after this i will jump into the impact
that source has had on our company and
how we had to rapidly switch course to
support medical institutions
i would like to introduce you to our
range of source assays and the devices
we have to support these and i am
delighted to finish with feedback from
our customer ava lab in portugal
let me give a brief glimpse into the
history of our company
founded in 1986 as a laboratory supplier
the company grew to what it is today
evolving from simple resellers we
started to develop our own diagnostic
tests and this image shows the various
milestones along the way
in 1996 we developed the dna strip which
was based online probe assay technology
which in 1996 really was state of the
art and actually even though for some
testing it might be considered outdated
it is still used prolifically with
mycobacteria assays because you can
collect a lot of information on each
strip
however as you may know while the dna
strips provide a lot of information they
can be quite labor-intensive
you can see that the evolution of our
innovations tended to facilitate faster
results with less and less hands-on time
moving from the dna strip to a somewhat
faster solution
the genocide this was also based on the
same technology as the dna strip but
gave
the user save the users considerable
time
next we had a series of breakthroughs
with fluorotype assays based on melting
curve analysis
these were complete pcr tests so
analysis was also part of the pcr
for the first time the results could be
measured with optical thermocyclers and
we ensured that we could facilitate our
users with devices to use these assays
next came the real-time pcr assays and
our latest solution based on liquid
array technology allows us to generate
high content information from our latest
assays
we are proud of the developments we have
had over the years and in 2018 decided
to join brooker where we combine our
diagnostic strengths
to go further in the overall offering of
what i will now informally refer to as
brooker hein you can see that we serve a
number of markets
hind life science is world renowned in
the tuberculosis market
and with a number of world health
organization endorsements in particular
for tuberculosis tests
this has historically been one of our
strongest areas
we have expanded our expertise to cover
respiratory disease which as you can
imagine has become a focus with the dawn
of source
furthermore we offer immunocompromised
diagnostics with viral and fungal assays
now with our latest liquid array
technology we are able to provide
multi-plex solutions on syndromic panels
liquid array technology which as i
mentioned allows us to generate high
content information from these assays
since we want to guarantee the highest
possible quality we also provide
extraction chemistry and instrumentation
for extraction
as well as the pcr cyclers and of course
easy to use software that comes with
these systems
as everyone here is a were in 2019 the
covert 19 pandemic struck
this was the worst pandemic scene since
the spanish flu
you can see here some figures of the
infections and deaths it is fair to say
it had a huge impact on all of us
while we remain vigilant today we
remember that initially this was an
incredibly tough time
as a key player in the life science
market we had to show leadership and
guide our customers through this tough
time
we all learned a lot and we are still
learning from this experience
we quickly realized that our customers
went from needing a broad range of
assays with a broad range of throughput
needs from low to medium or medium to
high throughput to needing mainly source
cover ii assays which would help them
deal with each new wave of the pandemic
and they needed these at higher
throughput
this timeline gives a summary of how we
responded to various phases of the
pandemic in terms of assay development
initially we went back to our
distribution roots and provided a
real-time pcr assay from primer design
this helped us to serve our customers
while we worked on our own assays for
which we could offer full solution with
our instruments
in may 2020 we launched our fluorotype
source code 2 plus assay which focused
on detecting the actual presence of
source
in winter 2020 we launched a multiplex
assay fluorotype source cove 2
with flu and rsv
in preparation for what we believe would
be the flu season
do you remember first hearing about the
variants
this caused a lot of disruption and
unfortunately the covet numbers that had
started to decrease actually started to
increase again
we responded quickly to this with an ruo
solution the flurotype sars cove 2 var
id to provide the market with much
needed fast results
we were able to do this at this stage
with pcr instead of needing gene
sequencing
in may this year we launched the
ibd-registered assay fluorotype source
code 2 variety q
which like the one before it detects the
variance and additionally provides
quantification of viral load in
accordance with the world health
organization recommendations
and then as you know another way of a
variance arose and we released our
latest assay the fluorotype sars cove ii
evo
again as an ru to ensure that we support
our customers as quickly as possible
i will go through most of these assays
to give an idea of the differences and
the advantages of each
as i said the source code ii plus was
designed to simply detect the presence
of the virus
it is hard to imagine with our
collective knowledge today that only a
year or a year and a half ago
not so much was known about the virus
yet or at least not enough
for this essay we based the diagnosis on
a dual target this is a world health
organization recommendation that we
believe is important to adhere to
furthermore we wanted to be sure that
the virus detected would have a low risk
of mutation
and for this reason we carefully
selected the angine and the rdrp gene
in the section results at a glance
you're observing an actual report that
is automatically generated from the
software of the device
the results are displayed in the form of
graphs and summarized with the
conclusion text
from this report you can see how the
software presents the presence or
absence of the virus and provides a
written conclusion in addition to the
graph
on the top row sample 1 is positive for
source code 2 and on the next row sample
2 does not exhibit the search code 2
virus
as i mentioned already we prepared for
flu season with this highly multiplexed
respiratory assay
source flu and rsv
as a four in one detection it
significantly reduces the time compared
to testing for each compared to testing
for each virus and
individually
actually it is worth noting that this
assay can detect mixed infections
that means if a sample contains source
and flu or source and flu and rsv
these would all appear in these results
this report shows that the simple that
the sample contained only source but if
the sample had also contained a flu
virus then either influenza a or
influenza b would also be shown in red
and indicate that the virus is present
we launched this last year for our low
throughput extraction device the geno
extract however we know that people took
many precautions last year staying
indoors keeping social distancing and
wearing masks so the impact of flu was
less than in other years
while we still don't know what will
happen this winter season we are extra
prepared for this since we recently made
this assay available on our high
throughput device
did you know extract flex t
we responded to the rise and presence of
variants popping up with the source code
ii var idq
this assay can detect the presence of
the s gene mutations listed here and
importantly we can quantify the viral
load according to the world health
organization's international units per
milliliter
in the graph here represented by
deletion 69-70
and the
n501y
two peaks appear in the gray area
this combination informs us that the
alpha variant is likely to be present
please look at the written values in
this report and you can also see that
the international units per milliliter
are displayed automatically in the
software
how do we do this
well information about the world health
organization standard is encrypted in
the barcode which can be found on the
packaging of our assays
this barcode is scanned during the pcr
analysis and the software uses this
value to calculate the accepted
international units per milliliter which
we display in the result report as i
already explained and as you can also
see here
it is quite special that the user does
not have to do calculations on their own
but that the international units are
generated automatically and presented in
the software
why is it so important to quantify the
viral load
as you can imagine pcr results also
providing a viral load can be much more
valuable in many situations than a
simple positive or negative result
take for example patient management if a
patient has simply a positive result
this may cause them to remain
hospitalized or in isolation
however if a quantitative assessment has
been made the viral load will indicate
whether this person is still infectious
or if they are found to re-enter society
furthermore patients may or may not
respond to a given source treatment if
quantification of the viral load is
needed this can provide an indication to
the medical personnel that the treatment
is not taking effect
and perhaps another treatment would be
more useful
beyond this a person may be waiting for
treatment for another disease which
would be delayed due to the simple
positive pcr result
delaying of some treatments can be
detrimental to patients therefore if the
viral load is below a certain threshold
perhaps treatment for other diseases can
begin
finally for other downstream
applications like next generation
sequencing it is important that the best
samples are selected
the quantification can be used to assess
the sample quality for these purposes
our latest assay the source code ii evo
has an ru status to give our users
faster access to the assay since newly
emerging variants are of major public
concern
the avo assay can detect the source gene
and simultaneously differentiate four
different sg mutations
these are in turn used to help us
identify variants
identifying these variants helps to
track their spread and enables
epidemiological surveillance
and again you can see the result report
that would be observed in the
fluorocycler xt software
i have described how we responded to the
pandemic with our various source assays
and as i explained earlier to ensure
high quality results we also provide
devices
so i will go over these devices since
this helps elaborate on the workflow
we have a number of low and the number
of medium to high throughput devices as
i show here
the geno extract and the genome extract
flex t are extraction devices the geno
extract is a 12 sample device and the
flex t as we call it is an ex is an
extraction and pcr setup instrument for
up to 96 samples
95 when doing pcr setup
our pcr amplification and detection
devices are the fluorocycler 12 and the
fluorosector xt
today i will focus on the higher
throughput devices however keep in mind
that it is possible to combine the
devices in different ways
however please also bear in mind that
the source assays do not run on the
fluorocycler12
the genoextract flex t was launched in
april 2021 it is a reliable medium to
high throughput extraction device with
automatic pcr setup which means it can
be used seamlessly with the fluorocycler
xt
with minimal manual intervention needed
from extraction to results
after a short setup the samples
chemistry and various parts needed for
the extraction and pcr setup are placed
on the external docking tray
the software guides the users through
the few steps needed and the robotic arm
puts the parts where they are required
inside the device
once running you can move on to other
tasks
since the device is based on liquid
handling we can take advantage of tidm
that is total aspiration and dispense
monitoring which ensures that the
pipetted volumes are highly accurate
the monitoring feature ensures that
throughout the run any error that might
occur can be traced and affiliated with
a given sample or indeed a given result
this prevents stoppage time meaning that
an entire run is not spoiled because of
one sample
furthermore the erroneous result is
tagged so that the user knows to discard
the result from this particular run
since you load all deck items from
outside you don't have to bend yourself
industry and shapes as you reach inside
to place stack tools
this not only reduces time but reduces
the chances of contamination of the
samples
the result of this phase of the workflow
is the ready-to-use pcr plate which can
be transferred to the fluorocycler xt
for pcr analysis
we have mentioned the fluro cycler xt a
few times already this is a 96 sample
pcr device with dedicated software for
analysis and detection
it has superb quality where all aspects
of pr pcr cycles have been considered
specific to this workflow the pcr plate
from the geno extract flex t is heat
sealed then can be barcode scanned and
inserted into the floor fluorocycler xt
if you remember when i explained that
the items are loaded externally and
barcode scanned upon entry to the
genoextract flex t
the pcr plate would have been one of
those items
and this is barcode scanned before being
used in the fluorosector xt
therefore if connected to limbs then the
information can be traced
again easy step-by-step software guides
the user through the process and pcr can
quickly be started with minimal hands-on
time between
regarding the highlights indicated on
this slide the first point regarding
maximal accuracy and homogeneity is
referred to the highly controlled
internal environment where we ensure the
temperature is homogeneous across the
entire plate
the multiplexing capabilities refer to
our ability to support 96 samples
but because we can also look at these in
up to five channels this leads to huge
multiplexing capacity
this with minimal crosstalk means that
we do not need any color compensation
many of our customers brief about the
fluro software which is not only
accurate but is really easy to use i
think that you will agree from the
result reports that i have shown
throughout this presentation that the
reports are very easy to interpret
and please keep in mind that they are
generated automatically
in addition to this what i have not
mentioned so far because i am focusing
on the source assays which are our own
assays
is that the fluro software also has an
additional tool that allows users to
analyze practically any assay of their
choice
the comparison here at the bottom with
sequencing is made in reference to the
liquid array technology
this i will not go into in detail here
but you can hear more about this in a
future webinar on the 2nd of november
where my colleague dr sandra burak lange
will go into detail about this
considering tuberculosis and
mycobacteria
this slide is a summary of the workflow
that i just explained it shows that we
start obviously with the samples which
with the chemistry and the other parts
needed are automatically barcode scanned
upon entry into the genoextract flex t
where extraction and pcr setup takes
place
the resulting pcr plate is automatically
tracked from the genoextract flex t to
the fluorocycler xt
by means of simple barcode scanning
when connected to the limbs of the lab
this makes the results much easier to
track to patient samples
then results are clearly presented in
the software reports
our take-home message is that we can
provide fast results at top quality with
the combination of hardware software and
of course the assays there is certainty
in every step of the process from
extraction to pcr analysis
i have saved the best for last and ways
to use the last few minutes to introduce
our customer ava lab established in
aveiro in portugal this lab has become
one of the most important national labs
in portugal
they are renowned for their high
scientific quality ability to recruit
and utilize state-of-the-art technology
and their strong experience
ava lab is therefore known as one of the
most experienced laboratories in
clinical analysis in portugal
the location we discuss here in aveiro
has more than 100 employees
the molecular biology department is
fully equipped with an extraction room
and an amplification detection room
the extraction room is equipped with six
geno extracts a geno extract flex tee
and two safety cabinets
the amplification and detection room is
equipped with three fluorocycler xt's a
fluorosector 12 and another biological
safety cabinet
the lab runs source assays hla b27 and
mrsa
avalab participate in quality control
programs including the qcmd and also the
world health organization for source
cove 2.
by the way this picture was taken
recently as my colleague was providing
the training for the geno extract flex t
like all labs around the world when
covert 19 struck avalab had to respond
to a sudden surge in sample processing
in july 2020 the sample numbers
increased to 120 samples per day
at this time point they purchased the
fluorocegular xt and the genoextrict
in august 2020 they needed another geno
extract
then as the sample demand increased to
1600 samples per day that is 1600
samples in one day
they not only needed another geno
extract in september but i was informed
that staff were working for more than 18
hours per day to get through the sample
volume
in november they needed another fluro
cycler xt and geno extract
but it didn't stop there
in july this year they took on another
fluro cycler xt and two more geno
extracts
and in august this year they were our
prized first customers of the geno
extract flex t which they tell us has
improved the quality and ensure
traceability of the results
here is dr elizabeth costa the
supervisor of the molecular biology
department dr costa was generous enough
to have some calls with me even during
her maternity leave to say a few words
about our systems
explaining that we have the simplest
extraction and amplification protocols
that are easy and quick to understand
this is exactly what we like to hear and
hope to continue to serve dr costa and
avalab
dr costa further commented on our
flourocycler xt
saying that the software is reliable and
easy to interpret
it provides high specificity and
sensitivity and the chance of human
errors are decreased
she also told us that the lab had the
chance to prove the accuracy of their
results comparing with international
labs from around the world proving that
the results were correct
i would like to take this opportunity to
thank dr costa for this wonderful
feedback and wish eva lab every success
i would also like to thank my colleagues
whose knowledge and expertise and
compiling this report
for you has been invaluable
finally and importantly i would like to
thank you the listeners thank you for
your time and your attention
thank you dr monahan for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you would like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for
also joining us for the q a we have
alina mertz senior product manager of
sars assays
okay let's get started our first
question is
how long does it take from sample to
result
thank you for your question um
so the the from sample to result it
would take some minutes to of startup
time and then it takes up to around
about two and a half
hours for the extraction obviously this
is for 96 samples obviously this is less
when
less samples are extracted
then it takes an additional 18 minutes
for the pcr setup
and also please keep in mind that
there's no hands-on time in between
these two steps
and then it's approximately one and a
half hours for the pcr analysis in the
fleur cellar xp
thank you dr monahan the next question
what is the minimum number of samples i
can process in the gino extract flex t
so the minimum amount is 12 samples but
obviously as i showed the different
device um
different devices in the portfolio when
when people want to measure
i say only but when 12 samples are
approximately what would be desired then
i would say probably best to use the
geno extract but the minimum is 12 and
up until any amount up until 96 yeah
all right thank you again dr monahan our
next question
in the multiplex test do you detect rsva
and rsvb
yeah hi this is lina speaking we are
actually detecting both of them however
in this case we do not differentiate
them or identify them
thank you alina
our next question today
which sars target do you use to quantify
well for the quantitative sales essay we
use the rdrp gene for the quantification
however the the target for the cells
result would be both the rdrp gene and
the ng
thank you again alina our next question
i have a fluorocyclo12 can i use this
with the sars and flex t
um actually
unfortunately no the fluorocycler12
doesn't um hasn't been validated for the
source assays and so that would be the
fluorocyclorexp would be the the best
lyrocycler to use in that case
all right thank you dr monahan uh looks
like we have time for one more question
here
outside of the pandemic what other
diagnostic solutions will be available
on these platforms
um that's a lovely question um so
outside of the pandemic that would be
so um earlier on in the presentation i
gave the overview of the expertise um
the the list of essays that we provide
and actually we are working towards
validating these assays on both the geno
extract flex t
and the fluorocycloxy together
all right thank you again dr monahan for
your time today and for your important
research we would also like to thank
alina for joining us for the q and a
session for your time we appreciate it
and we would also like to thank
labyrinth and our sponsor brooker
daltonix for underwriting today's
educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event
until next time
goodbye